From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life, distributed by Public Radio International. And today we have a big, big story of money and politics. It begins with a humble voice now.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共电台发行。今天，我们要讲一个关于金钱与政治的宏大故事。故事要从一个谦卑的声音说起。
This is Eleanor Norton, Congresswoman Eleanor Holmes Norton. I noticed that you have given to other colleagues on the Transportation and Infrastructure Committee. I am a senior member, a 20-year veteran and--
我是埃莉诺·诺顿，国会议员埃莉诺·霍姆斯·诺顿。我注意到你曾经给交通和基础设施委员会的其他同事捐过款。我是该委员会的资深成员，有20年的资历，而且……
This is voicemail that Eleanor Holmes Norton, the Democratic congresswoman from Washington DC, left for a lobbyist in the fall of 2010. We don't know who the lobbyist is, but from the voicemail we can infer that he represents a contractor who's working on the new Homeland Security complex being built in Washington DC-- a complex that Eleanor their Holmes Norton, at the time, had a lot of power over.
这是来自华盛顿特区的民主党国会议员埃莉诺·霍姆斯·诺顿在2010年秋天给一位说客留下的语音留言。我们不知道这位说客是谁，但从留言中可以推断，他代表了一家承包商，该公司正在承建华盛顿特区的新国土安全大楼——一个当时在埃莉诺·霍姆斯·诺顿权力管辖范围内的综合项目。
I'm handling the largest economic development project in the United States now, the Homeland Security compound of three buildings being built on the old St. Elizabeth hospital site--
我现在负责美国最大的经济发展项目，即建在旧圣伊丽莎白医院旧址上的三栋国土安全大楼……
After pointing out that she is in charge of the project that he cares about, she gets to the point.
在指出她负责对方所关心的项目后，她直接切入了正题。
I was, frankly, surprised to see that we don't have a record-- so far as I can tell-- of your having given to me, despite my long and deep work, essentially in your sector. I'm simply candidly calling to ask for a contribution. I'm asking you to give to Citizens for Eleanor Holmes Norton, PO Box 70626, DC, 20024.
坦白说，我很惊讶地发现，据我所知，我们这里没有记录显示你曾向我捐过款，尽管我在你的领域做了大量深入的工作。我打电话只是直白地向你请求一笔捐款。我请求你向“埃莉诺·霍姆斯·诺顿公民委员会”捐款，邮政信箱70626，华盛顿特区，邮编20024。
This tape first surfaced on the Andrew Breitbart site, Big Government. The source was the lobbyist, and redacted his own name from the beginning of the tape. Eleanor Holmes Norton verified that it was real. She declined to talk to us for this program. This voicemail of a US congresswoman sounding a lot like a telemarketer is a peek behind a curtain that usually we don't get a chance to peek behind. It's a part of our political process that we all know exists-- the money gathering part-- but we usually don't get a chance to witness.
这段录音最早出现在安德鲁·布莱巴特的网站“大政府”上。消息来源正是那位说客，他在录音开头隐去了自己的名字。埃莉诺·霍姆斯·诺顿证实了录音的真实性。她拒绝就此节目接受我们的采访。这位听起来很像电话推销员的美国国会议员的语音留言，让我们得以一窥平时很难见到的幕后。这是我们都知道存在的政治运作过程——金钱募集环节——但我们通常没有机会目睹。
Politicians usually don't like reporters and film crews present when they ask for cash. Most of them never want to talk about it with a reporter. But it is daily life for pretty much every member of Congress, their staffs, lobbyists. Phone I calls like this are happening all day, every day. There are phone banks, literally phone banks, in offices in Washington DC, where congresspeople are making calls like this one, leaving messages just like this one.
政治人物通常不喜欢记者和摄制组在他们要求捐款时在场。大多数人从不想和记者谈论这件事。但这对几乎每一位国会议员、他们的幕僚和说客来说，都是日常生活。像这样的电话每天都在发生。在华盛顿特区的办公室里，确实有电话中心，国会议员们就在那里拨打这样的电话，留下这样的信息。
And don't just take it from me. Here is the second in command of the US Senate, Dick Durbin, Democrat from Illinois.
别只听我一个人说。这是美国参议院二号人物、来自伊利诺伊州的民主党人迪克·德宾。
I think most Americans would be shocked-- not surprised, but shocked-- if they knew how much time a United States senator spends raising money. And how much time we spend talking about raising money, and thinking about raising money, and planning to raise money. And, you know, going off on little retreats and conjuring up new ideas on how to raise money.
我想大多数美国人如果知道一位美国参议员花了多少时间在筹款上，都会感到震惊——不是惊讶，而是震惊。我们花了多少时间谈论筹款、思考筹款、计划筹款。而且，你知道，去参加各种小型的闭门会议，绞尽脑汁想出新的筹款点子。
Well, today on our program, we will shock you. Alex Blumberg, from our Planet Money team has joined forces with NPR's Congressional correspondent, Andrea Seabrook, to take us deep inside this world that is hidden in plain sight. The world of lobbyists and money and political fundraising. A world that we all hear about all the time, but most of us never have seen up close.
那么，今天在我们的节目中，我们将让你大开眼界。我们“金钱星球”团队的亚历克斯·布隆伯格与NPR国会记者安德里亚·西布鲁克联手，带我们深入这个隐藏在众目睽睽之下的世界。说客、金钱和政治筹款的世界。一个我们一直听说，但大多数人从未近距离接触过的世界。
They talk to the people who need the money, they talk to the people who give the money, and they try to figure out what exactly the money buys. Also, there's this little Supreme Court case you may have heard about, Citizens United. We'll talk about that as well. And we bring the old band back together-- McCain and Feingold, here on the radio. Original cast, no substitutions. Stay with us.
他们与需要钱的人交谈，与给钱的人交谈，并试图弄清楚这些钱到底买到了什么。此外，还有一个你可能听说过的最高法院案件——“公民联合”案。我们也会谈论这个。我们还要把老乐队重新召集起来——麦凯恩和费恩戈尔德，就在电台里。原班人马，绝无替补。请继续收听。
Act One, The Hamster Wheel. Alex and Andrea start off our hour at the spots where the money actually changes hands.
第一幕，仓鼠轮。亚历克斯和安德里亚从金钱真正易手的地方开始了我们的节目。
The money changes hands in very specific places all over DC. There are townhouses whose sole function is to be rented out as venues for this. Dozens of restaurants do a booming business catering small parties in private rooms.
金钱在华盛顿各处的特定场所易手。有些联排别墅唯一的用途就是出租作为此类活动的场地。几十家餐馆靠在私密包间承办小型派对大赚一笔。
And if you have an idea in your head of what a political fundraiser is-- I know I did-- get it out. It is not that super fancy, black tie gala event you hear about, like the one Barack Obama went to with the $30,000 a plate dinner and Alicia keys performing. It is not that at all. These are much more mundane.
如果你脑海中对政治筹款会有一个固定的印象——我知道我曾有过——那么请把它忘掉。它绝不是你听说的那种超级奢华、穿着礼服的晚宴，比如奥巴马参加的那种每盘30000美元、还有艾莉西亚·凯斯表演的活动。完全不是那样。这些活动平庸得多。
Like this one here. Here's an invitation to one for Rep. Tim Bishop. He's a Democrat from New York. It's at a restaurant called Johnny's Half Shell. Costs you between $500 and $2,500 to get in. The time? 8:30 in the morning.
比如这个。这是一张蒂姆·毕晓普众议员的筹款邀请函。他是纽约州的民主党人。地点在一家叫“约翰尼半壳”的餐馆。入场费在500美元到2500美元之间。时间？早上8点半。
Breakfast. See? Not glamorous. A lot of these fundraisers happen at breakfast. Or at lunch, like this one for a Republican candidate, Steve Daines of Montana. It's at the offices of a big trade group in town. Maybe 15, 20 people munching appetizers in a conference room.
早餐。看到了吗？一点都不光鲜。许多筹款会都安排在早餐时间。或者午餐时间，就像共和党候选人、蒙大拿州的史蒂夫·戴恩斯的那场一样。地点就在城里一家大型贸易集团的办公室。可能只有15到20个人在会议室里吃着开胃小菜。
A congressional watchdog group called the Sunlight Foundation collects these invitations to fundraisers and puts them online. Sifting through them, the same venues come up again and again. Lunch at the Capitol Grille, dinner at Bullfeathers, cocktails at the Monocle, breakfast at Johnny's Half Shell.
一个叫“阳光基金会”的国会监督组织收集了这些筹款邀请函并将其发布在网上。浏览这些函件，会发现同样的场地一次又一次地出现。国会大厦烧烤店的午餐、公牛羽餐馆的晚餐、单片眼镜酒廊的鸡尾酒会、约翰尼半壳的早餐。
Now, occasionally they do get fancy. You'll see fundraisers at golf clubs or hockey games, pheasant hunts-- yes, pheasant hunts-- or at live events. For example, this past week, for $1,000, you could join South Dakota Senator John Thune at a Van Halen concert.
当然，偶尔他们也会搞得高级一点。你会看到在高尔夫俱乐部、曲棍球比赛、雉鸡狩猎——没错，雉鸡狩猎——或者现场活动上举行的筹款会。例如，就在上周，花1000美元，你就可以加入南达科他州参议员约翰·图恩去参加范·海伦乐队的演唱会。
Now all of these events just happened. Just in the last week actually. Our analysis with the Sunlight Foundation data shows that in peak fundraising months, there are at least 20 events a day. One lawmaker told us, "You could spend every day of the year raising money."
所有这些活动都是刚刚发生的。实际上就在上周。我们对阳光基金会数据的分析显示，在筹款高峰期，每天至少有20场此类活动。一位议员告诉我们：“你一年中的每一天都可以花在筹款上。”
And in fact, some actually do.
事实上，有些人确实如此。
I'm very proud of the fact that this year we've broken all records for our donor contributions to our fundraising efforts. And that enabled us to outraise the Republicans this year.
我为今年我们在捐款筹集方面打破了所有记录感到非常自豪。这使我们今年筹到的资金超过了共和党人。
This is Nancy Pelosi, the top Democrat in the House. She's also the Democratic Party's number one fundraiser. Pelosi has raised hundreds of millions of dollars over the years. Close to $40 million in this election alone.
这是南希·佩洛西，众议院民主党最高领导人。她也是民主党头号筹款人。多年来，佩洛西筹集了数亿美元。仅在本次选举中就筹集了近4000万美元。
How many fundraisers do you typically go to in a given week, do you think?
你认为你平均每周参加多少场筹款会？
A lot. Yeah. Either on the phone or attending events. But I think they've said this year I attended almost 400 fundraisers in nearly 40 cities.
很多。是的。要么是在电话上，要么是亲自出席活动。但我记得他们说今年我参加了近400场筹款会，遍布近40个城市。
That's 400 for the year 2011. That's more than one a day, every day of the year, Saturdays and Sundays included.
那是2011年一年的400场。这意味着平均每天不止一场，全年无休，包括周六和周日。
Now we know from fundraising numbers and scheduled events that the leadership on the Republican side is working just as hard. We contacted all of them and no one would speak to us.
我们从筹款数字和预定活动中得知，共和党领导层也在同样努力地工作。我们联系了他们所有人，但没有人愿意和我们谈话。
Staff for the number two Republican in the house, Eric Cantor, said, quote, "We'll pass." House Speaker Boehner's staff said, quote, "It doesn't sound like a good use of time."
众议院共和党二号人物埃里克·坎特的幕僚说：“我们拒绝。”众议院议长博纳的幕僚说：“这听起来不是个好用途。”
And there's one thing driving all this activity-- a gnawing, relentless, voracious need for cash. To understand that need, consider Walt Minnick.
有一件事驱动着所有这些活动——一种如饥似渴、永不满足的现金需求。要理解这种需求，可以看看沃尔特·明尼克。
Minnick is a conservative Democrat who represented a Republican-leaning district in Idaho. He was first elected in 2008, and after he won, he took just five days off from fundraising. Then, two months before he was sworn in as a congressman, he was back raising money for the next election, two years away.
明尼克是一位保守派民主党人，代表爱达荷州一个倾向共和党的选区。他于2008年首次当选，胜选后他只休息了五天就又开始筹款了。然后，在他宣誓就职成为国会议员前两个月，他又开始为两年后的下一次选举筹款。
I needed to raise $10,000 to $15,000 a day, and you only do it by elbow grease.
我每天需要筹集1万美元到1.5万美元，这只能靠苦力去挣。
Let's stop and dwell on that statement for a second, shall we, Andrea? $10,000 to $15,000 a day. The typical cost of a congressional race is about a million dollars-- although, if you're challenging an incumbent, you need more. Minnick's goal was even more than that-- $2.5 million-- because he was in such a competitive district.
我们先停下来细想一下这句话，好吗，安德里亚？每天1万美元到1.5万美元。一场国会竞选的典型成本大约是一百万美元——当然，如果你是在挑战在任者，你需要更多。明尼克的目标甚至更高——250万美元——因为他所在的选区竞争非常激烈。
I would spend two or three hours a day as a congressman trying to raise money.
作为一名国会议员，我每天会花两到三个小时试图筹款。
That's typical for a member of Congress, and most of those hours are spent across the street from the Capitol, in special offices set up by the parties specifically for this purpose.
这对国会议员来说很典型，其中大部分时间都花在国会大厦街对面的特殊办公室里，这些办公室是党派专门为此目的设立的。
Special offices because federal law prohibits lawmakers from making fundraising calls from their own congressional offices. Neither party is eager to let reporters into these call centers, but we got a couple Democrats to describe what it's like in there. This is Oregon Congressman Peter DeFazio.
之所以是特殊办公室，是因为联邦法律禁止议员在自己的国会办公室拨打筹款电话。两党都不愿让记者进入这些呼叫中心，但我们还是让几位民主党人描述了里面的情况。这是俄勒冈州众议员彼得·德法齐奥。
If you walked in there, you would say, boy, this is about the worst looking, most abusive call center situation I've seen in my life. These people don't have any workspace. The other person is virtually touching them. Just counters on the wall with telephones and people eight inches away from you, talking on the telephone.
如果你走进去，你会说，天哪，这是我见过最糟糕、最虐心的呼叫中心。这些人根本没有工作空间。旁边的人几乎在碰着你。墙边只有装了电话的柜台，人与人之间相隔只有八英寸，各自在打电话。
We sit at these desks with stacks of names in front of us, and short bios, and histories of giving.
我们坐在这些桌子前，面前堆着名字名单、简短的个人简历和捐款历史。
This is Senator Dick Durbin, who says that on the Senate side, they'll have these things called "power hours" several times a week, where a bunch of senators will go into the call center--
这是参议员迪克·德宾，他说在参议院那边，他们每周会有几次所谓的“权力时刻”，一群参议员会走进呼叫中心——
--and make these calls to people who are our faithful friends and ask them to give money or have a fundraiser. And then, if we're fortunate enough, we end up attending those fundraisers that we begged people to do for us. I mean, that is part of the conversation. And this goes on and on and on.
——给那些忠实的朋友打电话，请求他们捐款或举办筹款会。然后，如果我们足够幸运，我们最终会参加那些我们求着别人为我们举办的筹款会。我是说，这也是谈话的一部分。而且这没完没了。
Where do the names come from? How do you decide who to call?
这些名字是从哪来的？你怎么决定打给谁？
The names come from a history of giving. And many of them-- it's hard for most listeners to believe-- really aren't looking for much. They want their team to win. In this case, the Democratic team. They don't ask for special favors. But there are exceptions. There are some who won't waste any time to tell you what they think is the most important issue in Washington as they talk about their donation. It is part of the reality of the life that I live.
名字来自捐款历史。对大多数听众来说很难相信，他们中的许多人其实并不求什么回报。他们只是想让他们支持的队伍赢。在这个例子中，就是民主党团队。他们不会索要特殊优待。但也有例外。有些人会毫不浪费时间地在谈论捐款时告诉你他们认为华盛顿最重要的议题是什么。这是我生活现实的一部分。
It's absolutely the most distasteful thing to do as a congressman, or a senator, or a candidate.
作为国会议员、参议员或候选人，这绝对是最令人反感的事情。
Again, Walt Minnick.
再次重申，沃尔特·明尼克。
You essentially wear out your friends and you wear out the people who are your natural supporters, because if someone writes you one check or comes to a fundraiser, they get on a list. And three or four months later you call them back again. And the best thing about being an ex-congressman is my friends now return my phone calls.
你基本上耗尽了你的朋友，耗尽了那些天生的支持者，因为如果有人给你写了一张支票或参加了筹款会，他们就会进入名单。三四个月后，你又要再给他们打电话。做前任国会议员最好的事情就是，我的朋友现在愿意接我的电话了。
Your friends started dodging your calls?
你的朋友开始躲着你的电话？
They do what they can help. They're your friends. But after you've called them three or four times in an election cycle and they've been very generous, they think enough's enough. And it is. I agree with them. And I hated to make those calls.
他们会尽力帮忙。他们是你的朋友。但在一个选举周期里你给他们打了三四次电话，而且他们已经非常慷慨之后，他们觉得够了。确实也够了。我同意他们的看法。我讨厌打那些电话。
Now, there is an easier way to relieve some of that pressure and raise money faster. A way that doesn't involve tapping out your friends. Just go to the people who already have big stacks of money set aside to give to politicians-- lobbyists.
现在，有一种更简单的方法来减轻这种压力并更快地筹到钱。一种不需要压榨你朋友的方法。直接去找那些已经预留了一大笔钱准备给政治人物的人——说客。
A lobbyist can throw you a fundraiser. A lunch a Johnny's Half Shell or a cocktail reception at Bullfeathers. And so, every week, lawmakers and their staffs work the phones, trying to find lobbyists to organize these events. Jimmy Williams used to get those calls. He was a lobbyist for the real estate industry for many years.
说客可以为你举办一场筹款会。在约翰尼半壳餐馆吃顿午餐，或者在公牛羽餐馆办个鸡尾酒会。所以，议员和他们的幕僚每周都会忙着打电话，试图找到愿意组织这些活动的说客。吉米·威廉姆斯过去常接到这些电话。他多年来一直是房地产业的说客。
A lot of them would call and say, "Hey, can you host an event for me?" And you never want to say no. Actually, no. You always want to say no. In fact, you always want to say no. But, you could look on your phone with these caller IDs and you would be like, really? I'm not taking that call.
他们中很多人会打电话说：“嘿，你能为我办一场活动吗？”你永远不想说不。其实，不。你一直想说不。事实上，你一直想说不。但是，你看着电话上的来电显示会想，真的吗？我可不接这个电话。
Oh, so you would dodge calls for fundraising?
哦，所以你会躲避筹款电话？
Oh yeah. Every lobbyist does. Are you kidding? You spend most of your time dodging phone calls. Oh yeah.
哦，是的。每个说客都会。开玩笑呢？你大部分时间都在躲避电话。哦，是的。
This was one of the most surprising things I learned about this whole process. The way most of us generally think about it is absolutely backwards. We imagine the lobbyists stalking the halls of Congress, trying to influence members with cash. But more often than not, it's the reverse-- the member is stalking the lobbyists, saying, "Hey, can I have some of that money?"
这是我关于整个过程学到的最令人惊讶的事情之一。我们大多数人通常认为的方式完全是反的。我们想象着说客在国会大厅徘徊，试图用现金影响议员。但更多时候，事实恰恰相反——议员在追着说客跑，说：“嘿，能给我点钱吗？”
And it's hard to say no, Jimmy says. Especially to a congressman whose work and votes he cared about. So, he'd say yes and then he'd have to round up a bunch of guests.
而且拒绝很难，吉米说。尤其是对于他所关心工作和投票的国会议员。所以，他会答应，然后他就得召集一大群客人。
That's why I call up my buddies down on K Street. From my buddy over at the credit unions, or my buddy over at the insurance company, or my buddy over wherever-- at the home builders. And I say, "Hey, dude. I'm going to do this event for this guy and he sits on the House Financial Services Committee. And do you guys have any money for this person? Is he in your budget?" And the answer was usually, "Yeah, yeah, I got money for that guy." And so, all right. So cool. So we'll come up with a date and then we have this fundraiser. And it's a breakfast or it's a lunch or it's a dinner or a cocktail reception. And everyone comes and they bring their checks or they mail their checks in. And then you have it.
这就是为什么我给K街的哥们儿打电话。从信用社的朋友，或者保险公司的朋友，或者其他地方的朋友——建筑商那里的朋友。我说：“嘿，伙计。我要为这家伙办这个活动，他是众议院金融服务委员会的成员。你们有给这个人的预算吗？他在你们的预算里吗？”答案通常是：“有，有，我有给那个家伙的钱。”好吧。太好了。所以我们定个日期，然后我们举办筹款会。要么是早餐，要么是午餐，或者是晚餐或鸡尾酒会。每个人都来了，他们带着支票或者把支票寄来。然后你就搞定了。
We're talking thousands of dollars that the congressman will make in just an hour. And imagine what this is like for the lawmaker. For someone like Walt Minnick, who has to pull in $10,000 to $15,000 a day. When his staff comes and says, "We've convinced this group of lobbyists to throw a fundraiser for you," it's a relief.
我们说的是国会议员在短短一小时内就能赚到数千美元。想象一下这对议员来说意味着什么。对于像沃尔特·明尼克这样每天必须筹集1万美元到1.5万美元的人来说。当他的幕僚说：“我们说服了这群说客为你举办筹款会”时，这真是一种解脱。
And my answer is, "Yes, I'll be happy to attend." And I get lots of those kinds of events, too. I was on the egg committee, and every egg group in Washington that wanted to host one of those kinds of events, I would be pleased to go to.
我的回答是：“好，我很高兴参加。”我也参加过很多此类活动。我曾在蛋制品委员会工作，华盛顿所有想举办此类活动的相关组织，我都乐意去参加。
And if you walked away with $4,000 or $5,000 from that, that was, a half or a third of what you were supposed to raise that day. And that was easy money. That was a lot fewer phone calls you had to make that afternoon, so.
如果你能从中拿走4000或5000美元，那已经是你当天筹款目标的一半或三分之一了。那是轻松的钱。那天下午你要打的电话就少多了。
We were curious, how exactly does the money change hands? Is it like handing the groom an envelope at a wedding reception? Does someone collect it at the door when you walk in? Are you supposed to be discreet or overt?
我们很好奇，钱到底是怎么易手的？就像婚礼上给新郎塞信封吗？你走进去时有人在门口收吗？你是应该谨慎行事还是公开进行？
The answer is all of the above. Some people pay with plastic. A lot of times, there's actually a space on the invitation to put your credit card number. Sometimes, you'll tell a staffer, "Just put me down for this much," and then you send the money in later. But some, like financial services industry lobbyist, Scott Talbott, prefer a more direct approach.
答案是以上皆是。有些人用信用卡支付。很多时候，邀请函上确实留有填写信用卡号码的空间。有时，你会告诉幕僚：“给我记上这么多”，然后你以后再寄钱。但有些人，比如金融服务业的说客斯科特·塔尔博特，更喜欢直接的方式。
We have a policy that all checks have to be hand-delivered. So we have to go up and eyeball the candidate and talk to them and deliver the check. In rare instances, we can mail the check, but for the most part we want to be there as part of the delivery system.
我们的政策是所有支票必须当面递交。所以我们必须上去看着候选人，和他们交谈，然后递交支票。极少数情况下，我们可以邮寄支票，但大部分时间我们想作为递送系统的一部分在场。
So you bring it with you. You have it in your pocket.
所以你随身带着。放在口袋里。
And I have left it in my coat pocket many times. My wife has said, "What is this for, this envelope?" That has happened.
我有很多次把它留在外套口袋里。我妻子问：“这个信封是干什么的？”这种情况确实发生过。
But why is that better marshalling than just doing an electronic transfer?
但为什么这比直接电子转账更有筹款效果？
Well, because it is the ability to help the candidate who is receiving contributions from multiple sources remember you, the industry, et cetera, et cetera. Wouldn't you remember if someone handed you a check, versus just got it in the mail?
好吧，因为这能让收到多方捐款的候选人记住你，记住这个行业，等等等等。如果有人亲自递给你一张支票，而不是仅仅在邮件里收到，你难道不会记住吗？
Hell yes.
该死，当然会。
Sure, sure.
当然，当然。
Talbot says, typically, there's the person who works for the member of Congress there, who's holding the checks. That person is called a "fundraiser."
塔尔博特说，通常现场会有国会议员的幕僚负责拿着支票。那个人被称为“筹款人”。
Yup, the event is a fundraiser and that person is called a fundraiser. Jimmy Williams picks it up with what happens next.
是的，活动是筹款会，那个人就叫筹款人。吉米·威廉姆斯接着说后面发生了什么。
You sit around and you have a conversation with the member who's seated at the head of the table or in the center of the table and everyone goes around and says, "I'm Jimmy Williams and I'm a lobbyist for the National Association of Realtors," or whatever it is. And then you go and you say, "We care about keeping big, bad evil banks out of real estate and we care about protecting flood insurance, which is the flood insurance program, which is great for coastal communities."
大家围坐在一起，和坐在桌子首位或中间的议员交谈，每个人轮流说：“我是吉米·威廉姆斯，我是全国房地产经纪人协会的说客，”诸如此类。然后你说：“我们关心的是把那些大而坏的邪恶银行排除在房地产市场之外，我们关心保护洪水保险，这就是洪水保险计划，这对沿海社区很有好处。”
But everybody does that, so the insurance guy, the lobbyist for the insurance industry, he does that. And the lobbyist for the accounting industry, she does that. By the way, the fundraiser is standing in the room. And the fundraiser has $35,000 in checks sitting in her pocket right now, in her pocketbook. Oh, and we're going to talk about public policy while we take the checks.
但每个人都这么干，所以保险业的那个说客也这么说。会计行业的那个女说客也这么说。顺便说一句，筹款人正站在房间里。那个筹款人的口袋里现在装着35000美元的支票，就在她的钱包里。噢，而且我们要一边拿支票一边谈论公共政策。
Jimmy says that it's not like the check will buy a vote on a bill, or even an amendment. But to get in front of the lawmaker, to make your case at all, you need that check.
吉米说，支票并不会直接买到某项法案甚至修正案的选票。但要站在议员面前，要能够陈述你的观点，你就需要那张支票。
People we talked to in this system said everyone understands the rules. You're going to cut checks from your PAC, your political action committee, to get access to lawmakers. But they tell us the rules are rarely explicit, although there are times, says Jimmy Williams. Like when he took a couple of clients to one Congressman's office.
在这个系统里我们交谈过的人都说每个人都懂规矩。你要从你的政治行动委员会开支票，以获得接近议员的机会。但他们告诉我们规矩很少是明确的，尽管吉米·威廉姆斯说有时候会有例外。就像他带两个客户去某位众议员办公室时那样。
They open up the door and the chief of staff said, "Can we talk to just you for one second, and then we can bring in the two constituents?" And I said, "Sure, absolutely. Not a problem." Walk in, they shut the door. The congressman is sitting behind his desk. He stands up, he shakes my hand and says, "Hey, Jimmy, it's great to see you." And I said, "Congressman, it's good to see you too." He said, "I have put in two calls to your PAC director and I haven't received any return phone calls. Now why am I taking this meeting?" And he held up a piece of paper with my PAC director's name highlighted in yellow on it, with the dates and the times that he had called her to ask her for a campaign donation. And she hadn't returned his call.
他们打开门，幕僚长说：“我们能先只和你谈一秒钟吗，然后再带那两个选民进来？”我说：“当然，绝对没问题。”走进去，他们关上门。那位国会议员坐在桌子后面。他站起来，握住我的手说：“嘿，吉米，很高兴见到你。”我说：“国会议员，也很高兴见到你。”他说：“我给你的PAC主管打了两个电话，都没得到回音。那我为什么要接这个会？”他举起一张纸，上面用黄色荧光笔标出了我PAC主管的名字，以及他打电话给她索要竞选捐款的日期和时间。而她没回他的电话。
And then I thought to myself, "This is great." Because I've got two of my guys out here that are constituents of this congressman, who are now going to come in here and they're going to make an ask of him to support a specific piece of legislation. And what he has done is he has warned me that if I don't take care of what my PAC director isn't doing, which is contributing to his campaign, then he's not going to help my guys.
然后我对自己想：“这太棒了。”因为我在外面有两个选民，他们是这位议员的选区居民，他们现在要进来，要让他支持某项特定的立法。而他已经警告我，如果我不处理好我的PAC主管没做的事——即向他的竞选活动捐款——那么他就不会帮助我的选民。
Some members of Congress have a much easier time getting lobbyists and donors to call them back. Members whose positions in Congress give them more sway over powerful interests. A lot of that depends on committee assignments. Here's Jeff Flake, a Republican congressman from Arizona.
有些国会议员能更容易地让说客和捐款人回电话。那些在国会的职位让他们对强大利益团体有更多影响力的人。很大程度上取决于委员会的分配。这是来自亚利桑那州的共和党众议员杰夫·弗莱克。
I can tell you the difference between the fundraising potential when you're sitting on the Ways and Means Committee or sitting on the Science Committee. There's a difference. There's a big difference.
我可以告诉你坐在筹款委员会和坐在科学委员会时，筹款潜力之间的差别。是有区别的。区别很大。
The Ways and Means Committee covers the US tax code. Who gets tax breaks, who pays more. Every corporation in America concerned about the tax code-- which is a lot of corporations-- is suddenly concerned with your candidacy when you're on Ways and Means. The Science Committee can't compete with that. Although, Science isn't the worst. Here's Walt Minnick.
筹款委员会负责美国税法。谁得到税收减免，谁交更多税。美国每一个关心税法的公司——那可是很多公司——当你在筹款委员会时，都会突然关心你的候选人资格。科学委员会无法与之竞争。当然，科学委员会还不是最差的。这是沃尔特·明尼克。
Well, I don't know the worst committees. Government Reform, Ethics.
嗯，我不知道最差的是哪些委员会。政府改革委员会、道德委员会。
The leadership of both parties actually ranks each committee according to its fundraising potential. There are lists of the A, B, and C committees with fundraising targets for each one. Those numbers aren't public-- many lawmakers say these lists exist, but no one would give one to us.
两党的领导层实际上会根据筹款潜力对每个委员会进行排名。有A、B和C级委员会的名单，每个都有筹款目标。这些数字不是公开的——许多议员说存在这些名单，但没人会给我们一份。
So we did our own list, based on publicly-disclosed fundraising numbers. Lee Drutman, a senior fellow at the Sunlight Foundation, crunched data for us, going back to the early '90s. And the math shows the best committee is indeed Ways and Means. Just getting on that committee earns you an estimated quarter million dollars more in donations than the average member of Congress.
所以我们根据公开披露的筹款数字制作了自己的名单。阳光基金会的高级研究员李·德鲁特曼为我们分析了数据，回溯到90年代初。数学分析显示，最好的委员会确实是筹款委员会。仅仅是进入那个委员会，就能让你比普通的国会议员多筹到估计25万美元的捐款。
Number two-- no big surprise here-- the Financial Services Committee. It covers banks and Wall Street. It brings in $182,000 more per member than the average. Third best-- Energy and Commerce, which has jurisdiction over the oil and natural gas industries. If you're there, you get a $142,000 boost in fundraising.
第二名——这没什么大惊小怪的——金融服务委员会。它负责银行和华尔街。它为每位成员带来的收入比平均水平多出18.2万美元。第三名——能源和商业委员会，它负责石油和天然气行业。如果你在那里，你的筹款额会增加14.2万美元。
And as for the worst-- it's true, Government Reform is bad. As are Education and Natural Resources. They all hurt your fundraising. Members on those committees bring in less than the average. But the very bottom spot belongs to the Judiciary Committee, which covers the federal courts and judicial nominations. Just being on Judiciary costs you $182,000 in donations.
至于最差的——没错，政府改革委员会确实很差。教育和自然资源委员会也是。它们都会损害你的筹款。这些委员会的成员筹到的钱比平均水平少。但垫底的是司法委员会，它负责联邦法院和司法提名。仅仅是留在司法委员会，就会让你损失18.2万美元的捐款。
And then there's leadership. According to the Sunlight data, having a leadership position on any committee-- even a dud committee-- will bump up your fundraising. So, for example, even the chairman of the Government Reform committee does very well, bringing in about a half a million dollars more than the average House member.
还有领导层职位。根据阳光基金会的数据，在任何委员会担任领导职务——即使是冷门委员会——也会提升你的筹款。所以，例如，即使是政府改革委员会的主席也做得很好，比普通众议员多筹集约50万美元。
And if you become a chairman of a powerhouse committee, an A committee, like Ways and Means or Energy, you pull in over $1 million more. Like Congressman Barney Frank. He became a leader on the Financial Services Committee in 2003 and saw his fundraising skyrocket.
如果你成为一个强力委员会（A级委员会）的主席，比如筹款委员会或能源委员会，你会多筹集超过100万美元。比如巴尼·弗兰克众议员。他在2003年成为金融服务委员会的领导人，他的筹款额呈火箭式上升。
People would come to see me and pay for the privilege of doing that.
人们会来见我，并为这样做支付特权费用。
But there's one catch to getting on a good committee or taking a leadership spot.
但进入一个好委员会或担任领导职位有一个附带条件。
Where much is given, much is required
能力越大，责任越大。
Jeff Flake, the Republican from Arizona, says once you get on a good committee or become a chairman, your party's leadership expects you to raise even more money and turn it over to them, so that they can spread it around to members who are less fortunate. Ones in tight races who don't have such an easy time fundraising for themselves. Remember that list of the A, B, and C committees? Flake says leadership makes those targets pretty explicit.
来自亚利桑那州的共和党人杰夫·弗莱克说，一旦你进入一个好委员会或成为主席，你所在的党领导层就会期望你筹集更多的钱并交给他们，以便他们可以将钱分给那些不太幸运的成员。那些身处激烈选区、自身筹款并不容易的议员。还记得那些A、B和C级委员会的名单吗？弗莱克说领导层设定的目标相当明确。
We were given dues and assessments. And if you're a senior member on committees that lend themselves to fundraising, and you're either a ranking member or you're the chairman, then you're expected to raise a lot of money.
我们被分配了会费和摊派额。如果你是那些有筹款潜力委员会的资深成员，而且你或者是排名成员或者是主席，那么你就被期望筹集大量的钱。
Or?
或者？
Or when you come up every two years to either retain your position or move to another committee, those things are certainly taken into account.
或者当你每两年需要保住你的职位或调动到另一个委员会时，这些事情肯定会被纳入考量。
Do they tell you this?
他们会直接告诉你吗？
I think that's implied. I think it's pretty well understood.
我认为那是隐含的。我认为这大家都心知肚明。
Lawmakers of both parties told us that if you're on a good committee, you regularly get called up in front of your party's leaders to go over your fundraising numbers.
两党的议员都告诉我们，如果你在一个好委员会，你会经常被召到党领导人面前过问你的筹款数字。
And let's say your numbers aren't that good. You know there are other congressmen out there hungry for your spot, trying to prove to the party leadership that they'd do a better job raising money if they were in your position.
假设你的数字不够好。你知道外面还有其他国会议员渴望你的位置，试图向党领导层证明，如果他们处于你的位置，他们能筹集更多的钱。
And you can hear this pressure in the voice of Eleanor Holmes Norton. She's the congresswoman who left that voicemail we played at the beginning of the show. This is a part we didn't play earlier.
你可以在埃莉诺·霍姆斯·诺顿的声音中听到这种压力。她就是那位在节目开头留下语音留言的国会议员。这是我们之前没放的一部分。
I'm simply candidly calling to ask for a contribution. As a senior member of the committee and a subcommittee chair, we have obligations to raise funds and I think it must have been me who hasn't, frankly, done my homework to ask for a contribution earlier. So I'm trying to make up for it by asking for one now, when we particularly need contributions. Particularly those of us who have the seniority and the chairmanships and are in a position to raise funds.
我打电话只是直白地请求一笔捐款。作为委员会的资深成员和小组委员会主席，我们有筹款的义务，我想一定是我没有做好功课，没有早点请求捐款。所以我正试图通过现在请求捐款来弥补，特别是在我们急需捐款的时候。特别是我们这些拥有资历、担任主席职位且有能力筹款的人。
And this brings us to the big question-- what does the money buy? What are corporations and special interest getting in return for the billions of dollars they spend lobbying each year?
这就引出了一个大问题——这些钱买到了什么？公司和特殊利益集团每年花费数十亿美元游说，得到了什么回报？
There tend to be two views on this. If you're cynical, you think money buys votes, pure and simple. Washington is owned. Money drives everything.
这通常有两种观点。如果你是个愤世嫉俗的人，你会认为金钱就是买选票，简单明了。华盛顿是被收买的。金钱驱动一切。
But lobbyists and politicians will sometimes tell you the opposite. Money has no effect. After all, they say, there's always two sides, and both are giving. Exporters versus importers, bankers versus Realtors, businesses versus unions. The money cancels itself out.
但说客和政客有时会告诉你相反的情况。金钱没有影响。毕竟，他们说，总是有两派观点，而且双方都在捐钱。出口商对进口商，银行家对房地产商，企业对工会。金钱相互抵消了。
When we asked Barney Frank about this, he said both of those positions are caricatures.
当我们问巴尼·弗兰克这个问题时，他说这两种立场都是夸大其词。
People say, "Oh, it doesn't have any effect on me." Look, if that were the case, we would be the only human beings in the history of the world who, on a regular basis, took significant amounts of money from perfect strangers and made sure that it had no effect on our behavior. That is not human nature.
人们说：“哦，这对我没有任何影响。”听着，如果真是那样，我们就成了历史上唯一一群定期从完全陌生的人那里收受大笔资金，却确保它不对我们的行为产生任何影响的人了。这不是人性。
On the other hand, he says, there are things that influence a politician besides money.
另一方面，他说，除了金钱之外，还有其他东西影响政治人物。
If the voters have a position, the votes will kick money's rear end any time. I've never met a politician-- I've been in the legislative bodies for 40 years now-- who, choosing between a significant opinion in his or her district and a number of campaign contributors, doesn't go with the district.
如果选民有一个立场，选票在任何时候都会把金钱踢到一边。我见过不少政治人物——我在立法机构工作40年了——在选区的重大舆论和竞选捐款人之间做选择时，他们都会站在选区这边。
And I have had people tell me-- and we talk honestly to each other, we don't lie to each other very often. You don't survive if you do. As chairman of a committee, I'd be lobbying for votes. I have had members say to me, Mr. Chairman, I love you. Barney, you're right. But I can't do that politically because I'll get killed in my district. No one has ever said to me, I'm sorry, but I got a big contributor I can't offend.
而且有人曾告诉过我——我们彼此坦诚相待，我们不常互相撒谎。如果你撒谎，你就生存不下去。作为委员会主席，我会游说选票。有议员对我说：主席先生，我爱你。巴尼，你是对的。但我从政治上做不到，因为在我的选区我会没命的。从来没有人对我说：我很抱歉，但我有一个不能冒犯的大捐款人。
But the fact is, most legislation, your district doesn't care about. The stuff that makes the news is a tiny fraction of what Congress actually does. They're deep in the weeds of tax law and business code and replacing the "and" in subsection b of title one with an "or." Things most voters have no opinions on. The only people who do care, or who even understand what that small print means, are the lobbyists and the industries and interests they represent.
但事实是，大多数立法，你的选区根本不在乎。上新闻的东西只是国会实际工作的一小部分。他们深陷于税法和商业法典的泥潭，把标题一子标题b里的“和”改成“或”。大多数选民对这些事情根本没有意见。唯一关心，甚至理解那些细则意味着什么的人，就是说客，以及他们所代表的行业和利益集团。
Consider the American Jobs Creation Act of 2004. This was a piece of legislation that lots of multinational corporations spent a lot of time lobbying for because it got them a huge, one-time tax break. Some of the profits-- the profits they made overseas-- would be taxed at just 5%, instead of the normal rate of 35%. A massive windfall.
考虑一下2004年的《美国就业创造法案》。这是一项许多跨国公司花了很多时间游说的立法，因为它为他们提供了一个巨大的、一次性的税收减免。他们的一部分利润——在海外赚取的利润——将仅以5%的税率征税，而不是通常的35%。这是一笔巨大的横财。
This law caught the attention of a tax professor at the University of Kansas, Raquel Alexander. She thought it might help her understand a pretty difficult question she and her colleagues had been considering.
这项法律引起了堪萨斯大学税收教授拉奎尔·亚历山大的注意。她认为这或许能帮她理解她和同事们一直在思考的一个相当困难的问题。
We know that people lobby for a reason, but we haven't really been able to quantify what's the return on their lobbying investment.
我们知道人们游说是有原因的，但我们还没能真正量化他们的游说投资回报率是多少。
With the American Jobs Creation Act, Alexander and her colleagues finally got something that could help them add up the lobbying costs and benefits.
有了《美国就业创造法案》，亚历山大和她的同事终于得到了可以帮他们计算游说成本和收益的东西。
They simply compared the amount that companies spent lobbying with the amount they saved on their taxes. They came up with a figure. A figure they called "the return on investment for lobbying." Now, for some perspective, money in a regular old savings account, you be lucky to get a 1% return on your investment. On the other end of the spectrum, Bernie Madoff advertised annual returns of just over 10%. If you want to come up with a big, impressive-sounding lie, a 10% return on investment is what you say. The return on investment to lobbying, in the case of Alexander's study--
他们简单地比较了公司花在游说上的金额和他们在税收上节省的金额。他们得出了一个数字。一个他们称之为“游说投资回报率”的数字。现在，从某种角度来看，普通的储蓄账户，你能获得1%的投资回报就不错了。在频谱的另一端，伯尼·麦道夫宣传的年回报率略高于10%。如果你想编造一个宏大、听起来令人印象深刻的谎言，10%的投资回报率就是你要说的。在亚历山大的研究中，游说投资回报率是——
22,000%. So, for every dollar, on average, that these firms spend on tax lobbying, they receive $220 in tax benefits from this repatriation provision.
22000%。所以，平均而言，这些公司在税收游说上每花一美元，他们就从这个遣返条款中获得220美元的税收优惠。
Were you expecting it to be that big?
你预料到会有这么大吗？
I was not. I was not expecting it to be that big at all. I thought I needed to go back and check my math again.
没有。我根本没想到会那么大。我想我需要回去重新核对一下我的计算。
So after the fifth or sixth time checking, you were like, well, this is the number.
所以在核对第五或第六次之后，你心想，嗯，这就是数字。
After the 20th time of checking.
在核对第20次之后。
In 2010, there was a total of $3.5 billion spent on lobbying. $3.5 billion. It's hard to imagine that every one of those dollars got a 22,000% return. There are certainly companies out there that spend a lot of money and don't get what they want. They've just lost money.
2010年，游说总支出为35亿美元。35亿美元。很难想象每一美元都能获得22000%的回报。肯定有一些公司花了很多钱却没得到他们想要的。他们只是赔了钱。
And it's not to say that the things they're lobbying for are bad public policy. There are lots of people, President Obama included, who think a lower corporate tax rate would benefit the country.
而且这并不是说他们游说的事情就是糟糕的公共政策。有很多人，包括奥巴马总统在内，认为较低的企业税率会有利于国家。
Barney Frank and lots of others told us straight up, a lot of times, the lobbyist knows much more about your subject than you do as a congressman. You depend on their expertise, and so you listen to their arguments.
巴尼·弗兰克和许多其他人直截了当地告诉我们，很多时候，说客对你的课题的了解比你作为国会议员要深得多。你依赖他们的专业知识，所以你会听取他们的论点。
The problem is, those arguments are accompanied by a large check. The other side of the issue-- you don't always hear from them. Again, Walt Minnick, the one-time congressman from Idaho.
问题是，这些论点伴随着一张大额支票。问题的另一面——你并不总是能听到他们的声音。再次重申，沃尔特·明尼克，曾经的爱达荷州国会议员。
The fact that you get to explain your point of view because you're a big banker executive, and that someone who is just a depositor in the bank doesn't have the time to come into Washington, doesn't have the financial wherewithal. So you may not get that side of the view as well articulated. So you may end up voting the wrong way because you haven't fully understood both sides of the story, even if you do have integrity.
因为你是大银行高管，你就有机会解释你的观点，而只是银行存款人的人没有时间来到华盛顿，也没有经济实力。所以你可能无法很好地表达那一面的观点。因此，你可能会因为没有完全理解故事的两面而投错了票，即使你本身是廉洁的。
Is there a time that you accepted a meeting and money with people that, in retrospect, you might not have?
有没有你曾经接受过会议和金钱，事后回顾起来可能不应该的情况？
I had some meetings I was pretty uncomfortable at with the lender, the payday-loan kind of lender. Some of the folks in that industry were a little unsavory.
我参加过一些与贷款方、那种发薪日贷款方举行的会议，让我感到很不舒服。那个行业里有些人确实有点不光彩。
And they were funding your campaign?
而他们资助了你的竞选活动？
They contributed to my campaign. They're a big political contributor in Washington. And so that's an example of-- there weren't any people who were applying for payday loans that came in to see me. The consumer side of that doesn't contribute a nickel.
他们为我的竞选活动捐了款。他们是华盛顿的一大政治捐款人。这就是一个例子——没有申请发薪日贷款的人来见我。那一面的消费者根本不会捐一分钱。
When he was talking about this, Walt Minnick told us, "I think I was able to vote in ways I don't regret." That ambiguity, it's built into the system. And now he's on the other side of it. After losing his reelection bid in 2010, he became a lobbyist. And he still has misgivings about the power of money and politics to frame the issues and set the agenda.
当他谈论这件事时，沃尔特·明尼克告诉我们：“我想我能够以我不后悔的方式投票。”这种模糊性植根于这个系统之中。现在他站在了另一边。在2010年失去连任竞选后，他成为了一名说客。他仍然对金钱和政治塑造议题和设定议程的权力存有疑虑。
Money in the political system helps explain why oil companies get big subsidies, even while their business is booming. Why the federal government provides flood insurance for rich people to build beach houses in hurricane zones. Why corn syrup that goes in soft drinks gets federal subsidies, and fruits and vegetables don't.
政治系统中的金钱有助于解释为什么石油公司在业务蓬勃发展时还能获得巨额补贴。为什么联邦政府为富人提供洪水保险在飓风区建造海滨别墅。为什么软饮料中的玉米糖浆能得到联邦补贴，而水果和蔬菜却没有。
It helps explain why the Defense Department paid two different companies to make engines for the Joint Strike Fighter. Why you can deduct the interest you pay on your mortgage, but not the interest you pay on your credit card.
它有助于解释为什么国防部向两家不同的公司支付费用来制造联合攻击战斗机的发动机。为什么你可以扣除抵押贷款利息，却不能扣除信用卡利息。
It's why we have a system where, even though we passed a comprehensive health care reform bill, where it's still illegal for the federal government to negotiate drug prices. We pay-- old people, young people, people needing a new cancer drug-- pay eight or 10 times as much in America as they do in any other country. And that is directly a function of the amount of money the pharmaceutical industry has poured into congressional campaigns of members of both parties.
这就是为什么我们有这样一个系统，尽管我们通过了全面的医疗改革法案，但联邦政府谈判药价仍然是非法的。我们支付——老年人、年轻人、需要新癌症药物的人——在美国支付的价格是其他任何国家的8到10倍。而这直接取决于制药行业向两党成员的国会竞选活动注入的金钱数量。
That's our system. If a congressman went in front of a town hall meeting and said, for $5,000, I'll sit down with anyone of you and have breakfast. You can tell me exactly how you'd like me to vote. He'd be booed off the stage.
这就是我们的系统。如果一位国会议员在市政厅会议上说，花5000美元，我就坐下来和你们任何人共进早餐。你可以告诉我你想让我怎么投票。他会被嘘下台。
But that's the case for pretty much everybody in Congress. They don't even have to say it.
但这却是国会中几乎所有人的情况。他们甚至不需要说出来。
Alex Blumberg is a producer on our program and on the Planet Money team. Andrea Seabrook is NPR's congressional correspondent. On the internet right now, the Sunlight Foundation and Planet Money crunched numbers from over 13,000 fundraising invitations. Put together an interactive map showing the most popular spots in DC for hosting a fundraiser, charts listing the best and worst congressional committees for fundraising, how many fundraisers over the years have been birthday parties, golf tournaments, and hunting trips. That and more is at Planet Money's website, npr.org/money.
亚历克斯·布隆伯格是我们节目的制片人，也是“金钱星球”团队的成员。安德里亚·西布鲁克是NPR的国会记者。在互联网上，阳光基金会和“金钱星球”汇总了超过13000份筹款邀请函的数字。制作了一张互动地图，显示了华盛顿最受欢迎的筹款地点，列出了国会筹款最佳和最差委员会的图表，以及多年来有多少筹款会是生日派对、高尔夫锦标赛和狩猎旅行。更多信息请访问“金钱星球”网站，npr.org/money。
Coming up, how everything that you just heard is now changing. Changing in such a big way to give individual donors and corporations and unions way, way more leverage, thanks to the United States Supreme Court. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
即将到来，你刚才听到的一切现在正在发生改变。正在发生巨大的改变，由于美国最高法院的裁决，赋予了个人捐赠者、公司和工会更多、更多的杠杆。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共电台和国际公共电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, "Take the Money and Run for Congress"-- stories about the moment that money is handed to a politician and what it buys. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, PAC Men.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，“拿钱跑路去竞选国会议员”——关于钱交给政客那一刻以及它买到了什么的故事。我们已经到达节目的第二幕。第二幕，PAC男。
So everything that we described in the first half of the program-- the fundraisers, the phone banks of congressmen asking for donations-- all of that right now is, at this very moment, changing dramatically. The way that money flows into politics is changing because of the 2010 Supreme Court decision in the Citizens United case. Citizens United lifted a bunch of restrictions on political spending. It opened the door for unlimited political spending by corporations and by unions. And it gave birth to entities called "Super PACs." These funds can take, again, unlimited amounts directly from corporations, unions, millionaires-- anybody-- and spend it on politics. And because of the way the laws are written, Super PAC donors can either temporarily or, sometimes, permanently keep their identities from becoming public. Meaning that people can drop millions into any given race. They can write commercials, they can attack candidates, and voters will never know who they were.
所以我们在节目上半部分描述的一切——筹款会、国会议员打求款电话的呼叫中心——所有这一切在这一刻，正在发生巨大的变化。因为2010年最高法院在“公民联合”案中的裁决，金钱进入政治的方式正在发生改变。公民联合案取消了对政治支出的多项限制。它为公司和工会的无限政治支出敞开了大门。它诞生了被称为“超级政治行动委员会（Super PACs）”的实体。这些基金可以直接从公司、工会、百万富翁——任何人——那里接受无限量的资金，并将其花在政治上。而且由于法律的编写方式，超级PAC捐赠者可以暂时或有时永久地对公众隐瞒身份。这意味着人们可以在任何竞选中投入数百万美元。他们可以撰写广告、攻击候选人，而选民永远不知道他们是谁。
A lot of attention has been paid to what this is going to do to presidential politics, but where it is already having a big effect is Congress. Ben Calhoun tells how.
人们非常关注这将对总统政治产生什么影响，但它已经在国会产生了巨大影响。本·卡尔霍恩讲述了其中的过程。
Here's one pretty good example of how Super PACs are affecting American politics. Affecting the whole balance of money and influence. It starts in Northern California. Starts in the suburban congressional district around Sacramento. And it starts with this guy who was never supposed to win.
这是一个超级PAC如何影响美国政治的相当好的例子。影响整个金钱和影响力的平衡。它始于北加州。始于萨克拉门托周围的郊区国会选区。并且始于这个本来不应该赢的人。
Most folks thought, you know what, Ami? You can't win this race.
大多数人认为，你知道吗，阿米？你不可能赢得这场竞选。
Ami Bera is a doctor, a college professor, and when he ran for Congress in 2010, his chances were pretty bleak. He was a Democrat in a midterm election where Democrats took a beating. He was a first time candidate taking on a sitting Republican congressmen named Dan Lungren, and this was in a district that favored Republicans.
阿米·贝拉是一名医生、大学教授，当他在2010年竞选国会议员时，他的机会相当渺茫。他是中期选举中的民主党人，当时民主党惨败。他是第一次竞选，对阵在任的共和党国会议员丹·伦格伦，而且这还是一个倾向共和党的选区。
Just to give you a sense of how bad it looked, at the beginning of the summer, Ami Bera took a poll.
为了让你了解情况有多糟糕，夏天刚开始时，阿米·贝拉做了一次民意调查。
When we did that first poll, we saw that we were over 30 points down. So I thought, god, how are we going to overcome 30 points?
当我们做那第一次民调时，我们看到我们落后了30多个百分点。所以我心想，天哪，我们怎么能克服这30个百分点呢？
30 points. 30 points is a lot. But week by week, Bera got his feet underneath him. He shook hands, he spoke at events, gathered volunteers, asked friends and acquaintances for money. All summer he did this. July, August, September.
30个百分点。30个百分点很多。但每周，贝拉都在站稳脚跟。他握手、在活动中演讲、聚集志愿者、向朋友和熟人求援。整个夏天他都在这样做。七月、八月、九月。
You know, we did a second poll at the beginning of October. I vividly remember when that second poll came in and our pollster called us together for the results. And the one thing she said was, "Single digits, baby." We went from 30 points down to a tight single-digit race. And there was a lot of high-fiving going on, and saying, you know what? We might get this. And then a couple days later, we were in the campaign office making phone calls, fundraising, and one of the younger staffers was on the internet and pulled up The Rothenberg Political Report, which is one of the big political pundits.
你知道，我们在十月初做了第二次民调。我清晰地记得第二次民调结果出来时，我们的民调专家把我们召集在一起。她说的一句话是：“个位数，宝贝。”我们从落后30个百分点缩短到了个位数的激烈竞选。大家都在击掌庆祝，说，你知道吗？我们可能会赢。然后几天后，我们在竞选办公室打求款电话，筹集资金，其中一位年轻的幕僚在网上打开了“罗森伯格政治报告”，这是重要的政治分析之一。
Just quickly, when it comes to the art of judging congressional races-- figuring out which ones are really competitive, which seats could change hands, all that stuff-- there's pretty much two people that everybody listens to. There's one guy named Charlie Cook. The other is Stu Rothenberg. So this Bera staffer goes to a computer, looks at The Rothenberg Report .
简单说一下，当谈到评估国会竞选的艺术时——弄清楚哪些是真正有竞争力的、哪些席位可能会换手，所有这些东西——基本上有两个人是大家都会听的。一个是查理·库克。另一个是斯图·罗森伯格。所以这个贝拉的幕僚坐到电脑前，查看罗森伯格报告。
And he comes busting out of the room and says, "You know what? Rothenberg moved us to a tossup race." Everyone else had us leaning Republican, and Stu Rothenberg moved us to a tossup. When Rothenberg moved us to tossup, that was external validation that says, OK, game on. We've got momentum on our side, we're moving. The needle's moving in our direction. We can do this.
他冲出房间说：“你知道吗？罗森伯格把我们移到了胜负难料的竞赛中。”其他所有人都认为我们倾向共和党，而斯图·罗森伯格把我们移到了胜负难料。当罗森伯格把我们移到胜负难料时，那是外部验证，说明好，比赛开始了。我们这边有了动力，我们在移动。风向正在朝我们这边吹。我们可以做到。
Soon, Time Magazine and The New York Times were reporting on how competitive the race was. The Times actually ran a piece calling the incumbent, Dan Lungren, "endangered." All of a sudden, more and more people were looking at Bera like he was a possible winner. And people started treating him like one. Donations took off. Everything sort of continued to fall into place until one very specific day.
很快，《时代》杂志和《纽约时报》都在报道这场竞选有多么激烈。《纽约时报》甚至发文称在任者丹·伦格伦“岌岌可危”。突然之间，越来越多的人开始把贝拉视为可能的赢家。人们开始像对待赢家一样对待他。捐款激增。一切似乎都在朝着正轨发展，直到一个非常具体的日子。
It was probably Wednesday or Thursday, right before-- at the end of the third week.
那可能是星期三或星期四，就在……第三周结束的时候。
This is the third week in October.
这是十月的第三周。
This is the third week in October. So just as we're getting up to two weeks out of Election Day. And one of our team members says, "You know what? American Crossroads has made a media buy in our media market."
这是十月的第三周。所以就在距离选举日还有两周的时候。我们团队的一名成员说：“你知道吗？美国十字路口已经在我们的媒体市场购买了媒体时段。”
American Crossroads is a Super PAC, put together by some of the country's leading conservative operatives and donors-- most notably, Karl Rove. In the Super PAC world, Crossroads is massive. Moneywise, they raise a ton-- $27 million last year and this year. Their directors are prominent conservative leaders and their donors, who give millions of dollars, are big ones. For example, Bob Perry, the main donor behind the Swift Boat stuff. Perry's given Crossroads more than $8 million.
美国十字路口是一个超级PAC，由一些国家领先的保守派经营者和捐赠者组织——最著名的是卡尔·罗夫。在超级PAC的世界里，十字路口是庞大的。在金钱方面，他们筹集了大量资金——去年和今年筹集了2700万美元。他们的主管是著名的保守派领袖，而他们的捐赠者，那些捐赠数百万美元的人，都是大人物。例如，鲍勃·佩里，这是斯威夫特船事件背后的主要捐赠者。佩里给了十字路口超过800万美元。
But anyway, back to Bera, who, after weeks of picking up steam, has just found out that Crossroads is about to spend money in Sacramento. And it was a lot of money-- $682,000. When Bera heard about this, he hoped that at least some of that money was going to be spent going after this other Democrat one congressional district over.
但总之，回到贝拉身上，他在几周的势头积累后，刚刚发现十字路口准备在萨克拉门托花钱。而且是一大笔钱——68.2万美元。当贝拉听到这个消息时，他希望那些钱里至少有一部分是花在攻击另一个民主党人身上的，那人在隔壁的国会选区。
I hate to wish ill on another person who's running for Congress, but it's like, well, I hope it's going in his direction. So we did some digging around. Folks went to the television stations to see what the buy was like. And they came back a little while later and say, it's all going against you, Ami. It's all a negative Bera buy. So, it's like, you stop there for second and the pit of your stomach falls out.
我不希望在这个竞选国会议员的人身上发生不幸，但这就像是，好吧，我希望它是朝着那个方向发展的。所以我们做了一些挖掘。人们去电视台看购买情况。他们过了一会儿回来，说，这全都是针对你的，阿米。这全是负面贝拉的广告购买。所以，在那一瞬间你停住了，胃里像坠入深渊。
Not only does Ami Bera support Obamacare, he says it doesn't go far enough? Obamacare's $525 billion in job killing taxes isn't far enough?
阿米·贝拉不仅支持奥巴马医改，他还说它走得不够远？奥巴马医改中5250亿美元的杀就业税还不算够远？
This is the commercial that Rove and American Crossroads ran against Bera. Just for the record, Bera thought Obama's Health Care Affordability Act-- aka Obamacare-- he thought it was flawed, needed to be fixed. He did not say what the commercial is saying. And he told this to anybody that would listen, but it was hard to counter Crossroads's ad buy, which was in heavy rotation.
这就是罗夫和美国十字路口用来攻击贝拉的商业广告。仅供记录，贝拉认为奥巴马的“医疗负担能力法案”——也就是奥巴马医改——是有缺陷的，需要修复。他并没有说商业广告中说的话。他告诉了每一个听得进去的人，但这很难抵消十字路口的广告购买，它们在滚动播放。
When those commercials were running, what is your most prominent memory of either seeing it at home or talking about it with a friend or your wife? Is there a conversation or something that sticks out in your mind?
当那些商业广告播放时，你最突出的记忆是是在家看到它还是和朋友或妻子谈论它？有什么对话或什么事情在你的脑海中挥之不去吗？
Probably my daughter saying, "Dad, you're on television again. Dad, you're on television again." Because the commercial was running so often.
可能是我的女儿说：“爸爸，你又上电视了。爸爸，你又上电视了。”因为那段商业广告播放得太频繁了。
I know that every TV market is different. What does $680,000 get you in a week in Sacrament? How heavy was it?
我知道每个电视市场都不同。68万美元在萨克拉门托一周能买到什么？播放密度有多大？
A lot of commercials. Josh, you may know.
很多商业广告。乔什，你可能知道。
This is Bera's campaign manager, Josh Wolf.
这是贝拉的竞选经理，乔什·沃尔夫。
Yeah, it was about 1600 points, which means that the average viewer will see that commercial about 16 times. Which is a lot.
是的，大约是1600点，这意味着普通观众在那一周内会看到该商业广告大约16次。这很多。
The average viewer?
普通观众？
So the average person watching television during that week would have seen that ad 16 times.
所以那周看电视的普通人会看到那则广告16次。
In just one week.
仅仅在一周内。
So there's a reason why my daughter was saying, "Hey dad, you're on television again. Hey, there's that commercial again."
所以这就是为什么我的女儿会说：“嘿爸爸，你又上电视了。嘿，又是那个商业广告。”
Day by day, as these ads continued to run, the Bera campaign struggled to respond. Bera sent out emails, sent out press releases, talked to reporters, but what Bera really needed was money. According to him, the campaign had budgeted money for a late rainy day, but it wasn't enough to match $682,000. Eventually, the situation got so dire that Bera tried to bail out the campaign with a $400,000 loan.
日复一日，随着这些广告继续播放，贝拉竞选团队挣扎着回应。贝拉发出电子邮件，发布新闻稿，与记者交谈，但贝拉真正需要的是钱。据他说，竞选团队为迟来的雨天预留了资金，但不足以匹配68.2万美元。最终，情况变得如此危急，贝拉试图用40万贷款来拯救竞选。
And what were your most recent polls showing before those ads hit?
在那些广告出现之前，你最近的民调显示什么？
We were probably down by 8%.
我们可能落后8%。
But you actually saw-- you saw the numbers move after those commercials.
但你确实看到了——你在那些商业广告之后看到了数字移动。
Oh, absolutely.
哦，绝对。
Yeah. I mean, it clearly had impact and drove us backwards. We went from a single-digit race to 14 points down. Now, that's a lot to make up in a single week.
是的。我是说，它显然产生了影响并把我们往后推了。我们从个位数的竞选变成了落后14个百分点。那要在单周内弥补差距可太难了。
Of course, it's impossible to know if, without the Crossroads ads, Bera could've closed that eight point gap and won the race. Eight points is a lot of ground to make up in two weeks. What is possible to know, though, is that Bera could not compete with $682,000 in TV commercials. I mean, just to put that number in context, during the entire campaign, the Republican incumbent, Dan Lungren, raised and spent about $1.9 million. That means American Crossroads, when it spent about $700,000, it single-handedly increased spending on Lungren's side by more than 30% in a single day.
当然，不可能知道如果没有十字路口的广告，贝拉是否能填补那8个百分点的差距并赢得比赛。8个百分点在两周内要弥补的差距很大。然而，可以知道的是，贝拉无法与68.2万美元的电视商业广告竞争。我是说，为了把那个数字放在语境中，在整个竞选期间，共和党在任者丹·伦格伦筹集并花费了大约190万美元。这意味着美国十字路口，当它花费约70万美元时，它在一天内单枪匹马地将伦格伦这边的支出增加了30%以上。
I mean, it's like playing a chess game. You lay out your strategy and you're making your moves and so forth. You've taken your opponent's queen and all of a sudden he reaches into his pocket and pulls out another queen and drops it on the table.
我的意思是，这就像下一盘棋。你制定了你的策略，你正在走你的步子等等。你已经吃了对手的皇后，突然他伸手进兜里掏出另一个皇后，把它扔在桌上。
I did call Dan Lungren to get his side of all this. As it happens, Lungren's actually the chair of the House Administration Committee, which oversees the enforcement of elections law. So if Bera felt like this whole thing had been unfair, I just wondered what it looked like to Lungren, who had benefited from that big ad buy. I talked to his campaign, talked to his office in DC. After contacting them more than half a dozen times, Lungren never explicitly said he didn't want to talk about any of this. His staff just never responded to any of my requests.
我确实给丹·伦格伦打了电话想听听他对此的看法。碰巧的是，伦格伦实际上是众议院行政委员会的主席，该委员会负责监督选举法的执行。所以如果贝拉觉得这整件事不公平，我只是想知道在从那个大广告购买中获益的伦格伦眼里，这看起来是什么样的。我联系了他的竞选团队，联系了他在华盛顿的办公室。在联系了他们六次以上之后，伦格伦从来没有明确说他不想谈论这一切。他的幕僚只是从来没有回应我的任何要求。
You probably heard little about this because it didn't really get covered, but in 2010-- on both sides of the aisle-- Super PACs we're doing this all across the country. Swooping into congressional races, spending hundreds of thousands-- sometimes millions-- of dollars. affecting who was representing us in Washington. Again, lots of us weren't even paying attention.
你可能很少听说这个，因为它没有得到报道，但在2010年——在两党中——超级PAC在全国各地都在做这件事。突袭国会竞选，花费数十万——有时是数百万——美元。影响着谁在华盛顿代表我们。再一次，我们中的许多人甚至没有注意。
This year, we've seen a lot of headlines about this person and that person putting millions of dollars into the presidential race. But Super PACs can throw their weight around more in smaller races, like House races. There, every dollar is more influential. Put $5 million into a presidential campaign-- no matter how flashy that is, you're still ultimately just a drop in the bucket. Put half a million dollars into the right House race, you can change the fate of an entire campaign.
今年，我们看到了很多关于某个人投入数百万美元进入总统竞选的头条新闻。但超级PAC可以在更小的竞选中施加影响，比如众议院竞选。在那里，每一美元的影响力都更大。投入500万美元到总统竞选中——无论那多么引人注目，你最终都只是沧海一粟。投入50万美元到正确的众议院竞选中，你就能改变整个竞选的命运。
Every potentially vulnerable member of Congress is worried about a late-breaking, enormously-expensive attack campaign used against them.
每一位潜在脆弱的国会议员都担心针对他们的迟来的、极其昂贵的攻击性竞选。
This is Norm Ornstein. He works at the conservative think tank, the American Enterprise Institute. Ornstein's been living in the world of congressional politics for decades as a journalist, an academic, a columnist. He says these big chunks of Super PAC money that seem to be roaming around have everybody nervous. They've taken the pressure on candidates to raise money and they've turned it up even higher.
这是诺姆·奥恩斯坦。他在保守派智库美国企业研究所工作。奥恩斯坦作为记者、学者、专栏作家，已经在国会政治的世界里生活了几十年。他说这些看起来在四处游荡的超级PAC大额资金让每个人都很紧张。他们给候选人筹款的压力施加了更强的压力。
Imagine if you've got enough money to take on an opponent, even raise some money for your party, and two weeks before the election, somebody-- and you may not even know who it is, and certainly the voters aren't going to know who it is-- spends $10 million in a blanket television campaign defining you as a scoundrel, an alien, a felon, and a louse. You can't raise the money at that date to do anything about it. You don't have time. So what's happening now is more and more members of Congress are raising a protective war chest, just in case.
想象一下，如果你有足够的钱去对付对手，甚至为你的政党筹集一些资金，而在选举前两周，某人——你甚至可能不知道那是谁，当然选民也不会知道那是谁——花了1000万美元进行一场地毯式电视运动，把你定义为一个无赖、外星人、重罪犯和虱子。你在那个日期无法筹集到钱来做任何事。你没有时间。所以现在发生的是，越来越多的国会议员正在建立一个保护性的战争基金，以防万一。
Like a rainy day fund.
就像雨天基金。
You could call it a rainy day fund. You could call it an arsenal. A stockpile of nuclear weapons, just in case there's a sneak attack.
你可以称之为雨天基金。你可以称之为军火库。核武器储备，以防万一有突袭。
If you do the long division of what's happening, it's not hard to see where it's headed. That we're drifting towards a new version of Congress, one where there are people in the House and in the Senate who have had their political existences made or broken by a single entity, one single donor. Norm Ornstein says money, in these kinds of amounts, in some cases, people don't even have to spend it and it can affect what happens in Washington.
如果你做一下发生之事的长除法，不难看出它走向何方。我们正漂向一个新版本的国会，在那里，众议院和参议院里有人，他们的政治存在是由一个单一实体、一个单一捐赠者塑造或破坏的。诺姆·奥恩斯坦说金钱，在这些金额中，在某些情况下，人们甚至不需要花它，它就能影响华盛顿发生的事情。
I've had this tale told to me by a number of lawmakers. You're sitting in your office and a lobbyist comes in and says, "I'm working with Americans for a Better America. And I can't tell you who's funding them, but I can tell you they really, really want this amendment in the bill." And who knows what they'll do? They've got more money than God.
不少议员曾对我讲述过这个故事。你坐在办公室里，一个说客走进来，说：“我正在与‘为了更美好美国的美国人’合作。我不能告诉你是谁在资助他们，但我可以告诉你，他们非常、非常想要法案中的这个修正案。”谁知道他们会做什么？他们有的钱比上帝还多。
If somebody disappoints them, the implication becomes clear-- cross them and you're going to get the $20 million alien/predator attack on you and your campaign. And when they leave the office, the lawmaker is sitting there thinking, it's just one amendment, one little thing. And so what's going to happen here is, even without spending the money, in a lot of instances, there are going to be changes in laws that will benefit special interests because of the threat of millions of dollars in undisclosed contributions to bludgeon somebody who thwarts them.
如果有人让他们失望，暗示就变得很清楚了——违抗他们，你就会受到2000万美元外星人/掠食者的攻击，针对你和你的竞选活动。当他们离开办公室时，议员坐在那里想，这只是一个修正案，一件小事。所以这里要发生的是，即使不花钱，在很多情况下，法律也会发生变化，使特殊利益集团受益，因为威胁着有数百万美元的未公开捐款，用来重击任何阻碍他们的人。
You said that these are conversations that you've already heard of happening at this point?
你说这些是你在此时已经听说过正在发生的对话？
Yeah. I've had more than one member of Congress-- House and Senate-- tell me about having conversations like this.
是的。我不止一位国会议员——众议院和参议院——告诉我关于进行这种对话的事。
In this environment, Democrat Ami Bera and Republican Dan Lungren are going for round two. In some ways, Bera's got the wind at his back. California remapped Lungren's district, made it more Democratic. Bera's also out-fundraised Lungren. But at this house party event I went to with Bera, he took questions from a crowd for about half an hour. And Super PAC spending-- it came up three times.
在这种环境下，民主党人阿米·贝拉和共和党人丹·伦格伦正在进行第二轮竞选。在某些方面，贝拉有风在背后推他。加州重新划分了伦格伦的选区，使其更加民主党化。贝拉的筹款也超过了伦格伦。但在我和贝拉一起参加的这个家庭派对活动中，他接受了人群大约半小时的提问。而超级PAC支出——它被提到了三次。
What everybody seemed to agree on was that this big infusion of outside money-- they were all pretty much counting on it happening again. They talked about it as the new reality, because the role of Super PACs is only getting bigger. Republicans and Democrats are both amassing money. Everyone's planning to do more of this. Last time, Karl Rove's Crossroads group spent $37 million on about 40 different races. This time, including all the races-- presidential, House, Senate-- this time, it's been reported that Crossroads plans to raise and spend more than $300 million. And they're just one of many.
每个人似乎一致同意的是，这种巨大的外部资金注入——他们几乎都指望它再次发生。他们谈论它作为新现实，因为超级PAC的作用只会变得越来越大。共和党人和民主党人都在积累资金。每个人都计划做更多这样的事情。上次，卡尔·罗夫的十字路口团体在约40个不同的竞选中花费了3700万美元。这一次，包括所有的竞选——总统、众议院、参议院——这次，据报道，十字路口计划筹集和花费超过3亿美元。而且他们只是众多团体中的一个。
Ben Calhoun. He is one of the producers of our show.
本·卡尔霍恩。他是我们节目的制作人之一。
[MUSIC - "IF YOU'VE GOT THE MONEY, I'VE GOT THE TIME" BY JO STAFFORD]
[音乐 - 乔·斯塔福德的“如果你有钱，我就有时间”]
Act Three, The O.G.s. In the wake of Citizens United-- it seems like forever ago, but it was only a decade ago, in 2002, that Congress voted to reform how money works in politics when it passed BiCRA, the Bipartisan Campaign Reform Act, better known as McCain-Feingold, after the Republican and Democratic senators who sponsored the legislation, John McCain and Russ Feingold.
第三幕，老手们。在“公民联合”案之后——似乎那是很久以前的事了，但仅仅是十年前，在2002年，国会投票决定改革金钱在政治中运作的方式，当时通过了BiCRA（两党竞选改革法案），也就是众所周知的麦凯恩-费恩戈尔德法案，以赞助该立法的共和党和民主党参议员约翰·麦凯恩和拉斯·费恩戈尔德命名。
John, how are you?
约翰，你好吗？
Well, I miss you. You're not missing a thing, but I miss you.
嗯，我想你。你什么都没错过，但我确实想你。
For this last act, we wanted to talk with the two senators who have spent so much of their political lives fighting to lessen the impact of money in the political system. John McCain, of course, was the 2008 Republican nominee for President. He's still in the Senate, representing Arizona. Russ Feingold was swept out of office in the 2010 election. He'd represented Wisconsin there since 1993. He's now teaching at Stanford University. The two men spoke with Alex, Andrea, and Ben. And, listening to this interview, one of the things that stands out most is, well, how angry they sound when they're talking about the Citizens United decision. For example, McCain talking about the part of the Supreme Court ruling that says that candidates are not supposed to coordinate with the Super PACs that support them.
在这最后一幕中，我们想和两位把他们大部分政治生涯花在战斗以减少金钱对政治系统影响的参议员交谈。约翰·麦凯恩，当然，是2008年共和党总统候选人。他仍然在参议院，代表亚利桑那州。拉斯·费恩戈尔德在2010年的选举中被扫地出门。他从1993年起就在那里代表威斯康星州。他现在在斯坦福大学教书。两人与亚历克斯、安德里亚和本进行了交谈。而且，听这个采访，最突出的事情之一是，好吧，当他们谈论“公民联合”决议时，他们听起来有多愤怒。例如，麦凯恩谈论最高法院裁决中说候选人不应该与支持他们的超级PAC协调的部分。
The joke that they are not coordinating with the campaigns, it's beyond ridiculous. People who are part of their campaigns go over to run the PAC-- but they're not coordinating anything, don't get me wrong. Gambling is not taking place in this establishment. I mean, it's beyond belief.
他们没有与竞选团队协调这种笑话，简直荒谬到了极点。参与竞选的人跑去运行PAC——但他们没有协调任何事情，别误会我。这个机构里没有发生赌博。我是说，这简直令人难以置信。
What Senator McCain is referring to is the fact that the candidate's own staffers are often the ones who leave to run these Super PACs. A pro-Obama Super PAC called Priorities USA is run by President Obama's former deputy press secretary. Carl Forti who is political director of American Crossroads and senior strategist for a pro-Mitt Romney Super PAC called Restore Our Future, used to be Mitt Romney's political director. We'll pick up our interview here where the two senators are talking about what it was like the day they went over to observe the Supreme Court hearing arguments during the Citizens United case.
麦凯恩参议员指的是候选人自己的幕僚往往是那些离开去运行这些超级PAC的人这一事实。一个名为“优先美国”的支持奥巴马的超级PAC由奥巴马总统的前副新闻秘书运行。卡尔·福蒂，他是美国十字路口的政治主任，也是名为“恢复我们的未来”的支持米特·罗姆尼的超级PAC的高级战略家，过去是米特·罗姆尼的政治主任。我们将在此处接续我们的采访，两位参议员正在谈论他们在那天去最高法院观察“公民联合”案听证辩论时的情况。
At first, I was outraged. The day that Russ and I went over and observed the arguments, the questions that were asked, the naivety of the questions that were asked and the arrogance of some of the questioners, it was just stunning. Particularly Scalia with his sarcasm. Why shouldn't these people be able to engage in this process? Why do you want to restrict them from their rights of free speech? And the questions they asked showed they had not the slightest clue as to what a political campaign is all about and the role of money that it plays in political campaigns. And I remember when Russ and I walked out of there, I said, Russ, we're going to lose and it's because they are clueless. Remember that day we were over there, Russ?
起初，我被激怒了。拉斯和我去观察辩论的那天，被问的问题，被问的问题的幼稚程度，以及一些提问者的傲慢，简直令人震惊。特别是斯卡利亚的讽刺。为什么这些人不应该能够参与这个过程？你为什么要限制他们言论自由的权利？他们问的问题显示他们对政治竞选是什么、金钱在政治竞选中扮演的角色毫无头绪。我记得当拉斯和我从那里走出来时，我说，拉斯，我们要输了，因为他们一无所知。还记得我们在那里那天吗，拉斯？
Absolutely, John. I couldn't agree with you more. It clearly was one of the worst decisions ever of the Supreme Court. The trouble with this issue-- and I think John would agree with this-- is people have gotten so down about it, they think it's always been this way. Well, it's never been this way, since 1907. It's never been the case that when you buy toothpaste or detergent or a gallon of gas, that the next day that money can be used on a candidate that you don't believe in. That's brand new. That's never happened since the Tillman act and the Taft Hartley Act. And so, people have to realize this is a whole new deal. It's not business as usual.
绝对，约翰。我不能更同意你的观点了。这显然是最高法院有史以来最糟糕的决定之一。这个问题的问题在于——我想约翰会同意这一点——人们对此感到非常沮丧，他们认为事情一直都是这样的。嗯，它从来不是这样的，自1907年以来。从来没有发生过当你购买牙膏、洗涤剂或一加仑汽油时，第二天那笔钱就能用于你不相信的候选人。那是全新的。自蒂尔曼法案和塔夫脱-哈特莱法案以来，这种情况从未发生过。所以，人们必须意识到这是一笔全新的交易。这不是一切照旧。
The two of you, given the time and political capital that you put into passing the reform that you did--
你们两位，考虑到你们为通过你们所做的改革投入的时间和政治资本——
We've still got the scars to--
我们仍然留下了伤疤来——
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And given that, when you look at the current situation, I wonder if you feel a little bit like Sisyphus with the rock at the bottom.
考虑到这一点，当你看着当前的情况时，我怀疑你是否感觉有点像滚石头的西西弗斯在底部。
I feel a great sense of disappointment and sorrow, because we did see the corruption that existed before. And now you could make an argument that we've gone back further, even, than we had been before. Before there were at least some restrictions-- particularly on corporations and unions-- but now it's just-- it's inevitable as the sun will come up tomorrow. There will be scandals. I don't know exactly what it's gonna be, but I guarantee you, there's too much money washing around the political arena today.
我感到巨大的失望和悲伤，因为我们确实看到了之前存在的腐败。而现在你可以争辩说我们甚至回到了比以前更远的地方。以前至少有一些限制——特别是对公司和工会——但现在它只是——它就像太阳明天升起一样不可避免。会有丑闻。我不知道确切会是什么，但我保证，今天在政治领域流动的钱太多了。
I've had conversations with Democratic givers out here in the Bay Area and I'll tell you, you wouldn't believe the requests they're getting. The opening ante is a million dollars. It's not, gee, it'd be nice if you give a million. That's sort of the baseline. This is unprecedented. And, in fact, one thing that John and I experienced was that sometimes the corporations that didn't like the system would come to us and say, you know, you guys, it's not legalized bribery, it's legalized extortion. Because it's not like the company CEO calls up to say, gee, I'd love to give you some money. It's usually the other way around. The politician or their agent who's got the Super PAC, they're the ones that are calling up and asking for the money. So a lot of businesses, I think, are going to help us rebel against this and say, you know, we don't want to be a part of this mess.
我与湾区的民主党捐赠者进行了交谈，我可以告诉你，你不会相信他们正在收到的请求。开场的赌注是一百万美元。不是，天哪，如果你捐一百万会很好。那是基准线。这是前所未有的。而且，事实上，约翰和我经历的一件事是，有时不喜欢这个系统的公司会来找我们说，你知道，你们这些人，这不是合法的贿赂，这是合法的勒索。因为公司CEO打电话来说不是为了说，天哪，我想给你一些钱。通常反而是反过来的。政客或他们的代理人，那个拥有超级PAC的人，他们才是打电话要求钱的人。所以很多企业，我认为，将帮助我们反抗这种混乱，并说，你知道，我们不想成为这个烂摊子的一部分。
You know, Andrea and I and Ben and I have been talking to lots and lots of people who are involved-- politicians, lobbyists, talking to them about the process of fundraising. Most of the people we talked to hate it. They hate making those phone calls, they hate going into that room, they hate going to the fundraisers morning, noon, and night, they hate sucking up to people to give them money to get elected. Why don't more people try to change it?
你知道，安德里亚、本和我一直在与许多许多参与其中的人交谈——政客、说客，与他们谈论筹款的过程。我们交谈过的大多数人都讨厌它。他们讨厌打那些求款电话，他们讨厌走进那个房间，他们讨厌早、中、晚去筹款会，他们讨厌为了当选而巴结人们给他们钱。为什么没有更多的人尝试改变它？
After this program, I am going to a fundraiser for a guy whose name is Kirk Adams who is running for the US House of Representatives. And I can assure you, I would much prefer to be watching the first round of March Madness. So if I may illustrate your point, it's the system and it's the water in which we swim. And, as you say, I know of no one who likes it, but it is the system. I happen to think--
节目结束后，我要去参加一个竞选国会议员的叫柯克·亚当斯的人的筹款会。我可以向你保证，我宁愿在看“疯狂三月”的第一轮比赛。所以如果我能说明你的观点，这就是系统，这就是我们游泳的水。而且，正如你所说，我不知道有谁喜欢它，但这就是系统。我碰巧认为——
But why don't more people join you in fighting it? That's what I don't understand.
但为什么没有更多人加入你一起抗争它？这就是我不明白的地方。
Well, they did. We managed to get-- against all odds, we did get people. It took a lot of hard work. Now the problem is, of course, is people are reticent to do that because they got elected under the system.
嗯，他们加入了。我们设法得到了——克服所有困难，我们确实得到了人。这需要很多努力。现在的问题当然是，人们对此犹豫不决，因为他们是在系统下当选的。
So it's just fear of change?
所以只是害怕改变？
Sure. When you win a certain way, your people say to you, hey, this is how we do it and this is how we won. We better not mess with success. I think that's one of the problems in this presidential race, where not only the Republicans, but even my candidate, President Obama, has opened the door to this unlimited money through some of his people. It's hard to get people to change something after they win that way. And that's one of my worries about it.
当然。当你以某种方式获胜时，你的人会告诉你，嘿，这就是我们做的，这就是我们获胜的方式。我们最好不要搞砸成功。我认为这是这次总统竞选中的问题之一，不仅是共和党，甚至我的候选人奥巴马总统，也通过他的一些人打开了这扇无限金钱的大门。很难让人们在那样获胜后去改变某些东西。而这是我对此担心的原因之一。
Former Wisconsin senator Russ Feingold and his 2002 legislative partner, Arizona Senator John McCain, with Andrea Seabrook, Alex Blumberg and Ben Calhoun. Senator Feingold's the author of the book, While America Sleeps.
前威斯康星州参议员拉斯·费恩戈尔德和他的2002年立法伙伴，亚利桑那州参议员约翰·麦凯恩，与安德里亚·西布鲁克、亚历克斯·布隆伯格和本·卡尔霍恩。费恩戈尔德参议员是《当美国睡眠时》一书的作者。
Our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun and Alex Blumberg with Sarah Koenig, Jonathan Menjivar, Lisa Pollak, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder, Seth Lind is our production manager, Emily Condon's our office manager. Production help from Matt Kielty. Music help from Damien Graef, from Rob Geddis.
我们今天的节目由本·卡尔霍恩和亚历克斯·布隆伯格制作，莎拉·柯尼格、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔、丽莎·波拉克、布莱恩·里德、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普和南希·厄普代克参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德，塞斯·林德是我们的生产经理，艾米丽·康登是我们的办公室经理。马特·基尔蒂提供了制作帮助。达米安·格拉夫和罗布·格迪斯提供了音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
[MUSIC - "MONEY TALKS" BY THE PENGUINS]
[音乐 - 企鹅乐队的“钱在说话”]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. Life This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who is very, very concerned about the power of the atheist lobby in Congress.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由国际公共电台分发。WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督由我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生负责，他非常、非常担心国会中无神论游说团体的力量。
--and who knows what they'll do. They've got more money than God.
——而且谁知道他们会做什么。他们有的钱比上帝还多。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共电台，PRI。